[Music]
all right thanks everybody for coming
back to our second panel it was so much
fun in the first panel I can't wait to
see what happens or the second one we're
going to be hearing about the frontiers
of machine learning which is a great
segue I think from the topics that were
discussed in the last panel the
moderator of this panel is Kevin Layton
Brown Kevin is a professor at the
University of British Columbia and has
spent some time in the lab on sabbatical
so we we all really appreciate his
expertise he has a lot of work at the
intersection of machine learning and
economics and he has won the Edelman
Prize for his work in the FCC spectrum
auctions which he designs along with his
students and Paul Milgram to sell
spectra to the for the the auctions the
recent spectrum auctions so with that
I'd like to introduce Kevin and Wheaton
Brown thanks very much
well it's really a joy to be here at one
of the you know great meeting places in
our field for a really interdisciplinary
and you know talk not to work thank you
so much for having me and it's also a
joy to be here with this distinguished
panel so I'd like to begin by asking
each member of the panel to briefly
introduce themselves and briefly and say
something about their their affiliation
and their connection to sorry can you
hear me now
hi I'm Anna Marlon Kumar I'm a professor
at Cal Tech as well as a director of
machine learning research at Nvidia and
I work at the intersections of theory
and practice of machine learning you
know I have a lot of connections to this
lab you know this has been such a
nurturing and atmosphere in prime stages
of my career jennifer and christian now
amazing mentors you know some of the
early work the first work I did on my
core area of research on tensors started
here and right in this building so a lot
of great memories of this place and it's
amazing that it's been 10 years
congratulations we're gonna see whether
the learning panelists can learn to turn
their mics okay well we sort out that
mic let's keep moving down the line and
we'll come back to ya all right
oh yeah I'm dropping it now I think it's
on because I hear it maybe I have to
show us I think that makes her quit
directional so if you have it off to the
side you're gonna have to be careful not
to look the other way this is a big room
I know people in the back really
appreciate the mics where you maybe just
hold yeah okay yeah I'm you come from
the MIT Economics Department I also
represent here the Center for statistics
and data science
I have been involved in creation of
various programs educational programs
and statistics I my my shield is
econometrics which I define as the
intersection of economics with machine
learning you know at the beginning were
always involved my personal actually
well visiting here at Microsoft a couple
of some of this work when device machine
learning for actually here hi everyone
I'm Lester Mackey I'm one of the newest
researchers here at Microsoft Research
New England computer science machine
learning methodology theory modeling all
the problems I work on these days stem
from healthcare some weather and climate
forecasting high-energy
it's all good more broadly yeah here all
right
that's my microphone work out of the box
oh that's they see him be sabotaging
everybody else and I'm trying to move
away from Lester because I think his
microphone is picking me up so I'm gonna
call a Fuji I'm a researcher here in New
England I've joined this lab now three
years ago which seems it seems longer I
mean I bet as you're saying last night
at dinner you know time moves fast when
you have fun I been having fun but still
feels like more than three years than
some so I'm a machine learning
researcher by training I got very
interested in computational biology so I
worked a lot on statistical genetics
kind of genome-wide the seasons to the
studies methodology then I moved to
functional genomics with CRISPR gene
editing and then I kind of went back to
machine learning working on high
dimensional business musicians which as
you know under the name has been wrapped
under the name of automated machine
learning now and now I think I think
that the New England lab is one of the
few places in the world where one can
move from statistical genetics to them
doing some CRISPR gene editing using
machine learning to prove that obviously
and then moving back to machine learning
without serious career consequences in
fact like moving from field to field is
I feel like it's encouraged so yeah it's
it's great to be here all right thanks
everybody
so that's right as you guys can see
we're already modeling to you the way we
intend to continue which is to be very
informal hopefully maybe with working
microphones from now on so we're going
to encourage the panelists to make brief
statements kind of jump in as they see
fit on each question to speak more than
once to each question if they so choose
so don't don't think that people are
being unruly and bold when they do this
this is the way we've asked them to do
it so we're meant to be talking about
the frontiers of machine learning it's
no surprise that you know - any of you
hear that machine learning is having a
moment that you know computer science is
suddenly finding that machine learning
is kind of an
principle of the decade that so much is
changing about the way we work with data
and the way systems are able to self
organize based on that kind of data it's
almost a road map for where our field is
going as a whole sort of the way it
positions itself relative to machine
learning so so we have a way the
obligation panelists to chart the course
here I'd like to begin by thinking about
the frontiers by looking back so I'd
like to begin by asking each of you you
know with respect to your own work your
own disciplinary perspective to think
about where you were ten years ago with
respect to machine learning and what has
happened in the last ten years
that you found personally surprising but
from the perspective of breakthroughs in
machine learning yeah I mean I can name
quite a few like ten years ago you know
was merely at the time of graduation it
was also in in terms of the overall
conditions there was recession there
were hardly any you know jobs in
computer science so that's what it
seemed like right so we're so lucky to
get an academic job that were at a new
seer that that here and now a decade
later I mean the opportunities for
people in machine learning are just seem
endless there's so many great positions
in industry I mean every University
wants to hire more in machine learning
so in terms of opportunities now it
seems a lot so there's a prospect for
employment no I mean it's not surprising
but there's been a very big shift I mean
it's and it's happened much sooner than
I thought and there are indeed been
progress like you know what we thought
in terms of can we train these neural
networks at the scale and really get up
to these levels of performance in
practice that has been surprising to
everybody right and that's where I would
like to kind of you know being on both
extreme ends of the spectrum I've done
theory really thought deeply about you
know what kinds of machine learning
problems are hard what is the complexity
of these problems and being at Amazon
and now at an media I see extremely
tickle things where we have to launch a
product very soon we have lots of other
constraints we have customers having
requirements and so you have to kind of
also make do with what's currently there
right you can't always think about
pushing the frontiers in the next say
five years or so so being on the two
sides what I've seen is we need more
research in the middle ground you know
so there is I felt that in a way some of
the theory was holding us back because
there was a lot of pessimism you know
there was even a paper in my own field
of tensors for the title
all terms of problems are NP hard and
whenever I would tell people about my
tensor algorithm and our terms of method
that you know we were very excited about
people will be like but I thought these
are np-hard problems right so and it was
a similar thing with neural networks a
lot of empirical researchers for decades
felt like they were pulled away from it
because many people thought it was
impossible and so I have a lot of
respect for practitioners and the early
engineers who really said let's just
make it work I mean maybe it looks hacky
maybe it's not it doesn't like seem to
follow all the principles but just let's
see how to make it work right so that's
a great starting point and you know I
would not you know I have a lot of
respect for that and now the question is
how do we nurture that into a much
bigger thing and that's where we need
like research on robustness on you know
the how to do it with less data or how
to do it in a lot of different domains
how to scale up the problem let's not do
the whole panel in one question here
sorry I know we want to think you're
looking back last 10 years as concretely
as possible what surprised you
so 10 years ago I was starting my second
year of graduate school asked my
legitimate research and half of it
working on this um Netflix prize problem
that looks at losing him out with we're
gonna stew it is solve their
recommendation problem and it would
simply give you a million dollars if you
did that so that was you know I was a
graduate student and I remember thinking
so I remember thinking just a year prior
when I'm studying oh we're going
brackets for what to do that I had
flirted a bit with a lot of
disappointing leader signs so uh and so
I spent some time doing research in
programming languages without a
tradition theory and those both seemed
interesting to me but nothing's gonna be
quite the right fit and when I
encountered machine learning actually
via this Netflix brought has this
problem of I smell ratings you've given
voice in the past company predicted what
you were going to rate on movie in the
future I thought well this is perfect
and this is the future because it
combines people in a week information
for people whether they express in lens
mathematical modeling a statistics and
algorithms all the best parts of meter
science and math and people to me and I
was just shocked by the idea that well
we can learn so much about people from
their data and it was well just explore
that more and that's one every related a
you know that competition but also into
machine learning begin with and so this
is not really answered your question
because everything and they're all
surprised about what's happened to
machine learning it seemed to me at that
small bit like this would be the future
that everyone should want to be in this
field it just seemed incredible and
similar they had a lot of potential both
taking theory and translating into
practice and I think we're seeing more
of that yeah so in one thing that I
think about so ten years ago was in high
school not that's almost almost is close
plus or minus five years so if you if
you think about the machine learning
papers that were accepted to nips or top
machinery conferences in general ten
years ago you would see a lot of them
were well at least in probably see
machine learning where a graphical model
put distributions over things and then
three pages of gradients like how do you
die do we learn the thing that was you
know people that then got interesting
public program is salato that got
automated but if you think about it in
the course of ten years we kind of
eliminated we have various techniques a
bunch of those pages of papers so now
people kind of give to take them for
granted so there was a very very clear
process of make it work make it fast and
then make it like very easy to use and
if you think if you look at the papers
that are submitted to I CLR ICML these
days they build on this giant stack of
pretty solid automated complex work
there are all these probabilistic
programming libraries that you can use
and you can just build more complex
constructs and concepts and models in a
fraction of time and I think that's
paying dividends for the field so we are
we are getting through this crazy
exponential growth phase in in terms of
I have interesting measurable ideas that
wouldn't have been possible if we're
still all deriving gradients for a
little model so the first one was right
the first time I used the ANA which was
coming out I think from Milla maybe Tana
was this library that would you would
specify variables and it would kind of
do the gradients for you you could just
specify any model pretty much but it was
slower the first time I tried it and
then I tried it a year after it was
faster and and now we have crazy
toolkits to do this kind of work all
right you want to speak to this
not many people know the context here
but I saw a deer aggression the years
that say you wanna see me the demand
curve we need instruments to be good
instruments maschine
all right so I'm still looking 10 years
back let's now talk about what you found
your way you would've thought would be
working by now that's you know turns out
to be a disappointing failure what you
know what in retrospect has turned out
to be much harder than I I thought an
answer and then I thought oh maybe not
[Applause]
alright please please don't throw stuff
at me
reinforcement learning no okay so I
think when I first started looking into
reinforcement learning I thought oh we
are you know almost it's one of those
times where you think I'm I'm out
basically out of a job like people are
figuring it out as we speak and then and
so by the time I end up contributing
something it's gonna be solved that
hasn't been the case so in some sense
it's if people are making a lot of
progress but there is still a lot of
work to do and in some sense it's
getting interesting now I remember being
at a nips workshop on the frontiers of
reinforcement learning 15 years ago that
was everybody bemoaning the fact that
there was almost nothing realistic that
you could do with reinforcement learning
and that certainly has changed and
reinforcement learning has come along we
really named the card ball imeem I do
think like still realistic applications
they've been very few real use cases of
deep reinforcement learning especially
the ones that scale right so I think
like kind of I mean it's perfectly fine
to say we can solve games that are hard
for humans by training on billions of
examples but it's a very different
ballgame to ask how would we solve
robotics how would we automate
Manufacturing how would we you know like
really do automated machine learning in
the end at the end of the day right the
holy grail is you know ultimately you
know in their own backyard in their
homes people would kind of you know
without even thinking keep training and
personalizing their different AIP tools
and frameworks in say their personal
devices in their home or at work and we
had you know that's a long way in light
right now I mean it has become a lot
easier than what it was 10 years ago the
software frameworks have got an
amazingly good the computational scale
has been growing every day we are even
close to breaking the excess scale
barrier so the progress there has been
amazing but there is still I think
algorithmic progress to be done to ask
how we can exploit that to make it more
seamless you know to go from like raw
data to answers to a fully working AI
system with almost no intervention right
we are so far from that dream today
so whatever really concrete that you
know technologies or working use cases
would you have expected 10 years ago
that you're you're surprised not to have
seen progress on today this is a case
where we've had a lot of progress but
you know I'm surprised that we haven't
solved these problems so I think there
are lots of opportunities for using
machine learning very profitably in
healthcare but I'm a lucky part and
there's lots of problems that are
essentially prediction problem which is
like bread and butter and machine
learning supervised learning problems
classify this patient as someone who's
UN to respond or not in class you know
stratify the station in the following
way the major barrier is actually data
collection we don't have we have you
know small days of donations that are
heavily guarded we don't have any good
way of aggregating them across centers
different people of different features
of no standardization and that's one of
the principal barriers I think it's all
about all these problems making a lot of
headway in the cases I think when we
have had a big the senses are when you
know institutions spend a lot of time
and effort will be the days together to
get solutions so that's cool by the way
less people hold your mic a little lower
down yeah well let Jeff help you out
then you said you wouldn't do it I speak
there we go you got upgraded okay oh and
now I am oh oh I'm good
all right it's back on uncle can you
hear me
yeah good it's very important so one
talking about healthcare one thing that
comes to mind is so working compile and
intersectional compile medicine what
I've seen is and describing your a
certainty over your predictions is super
important and and yet you are kind of in
healthcare applications particular kind
of split in two fields either have kind
of poor predictors that give you an
certainty estimate start calibrated and
they're useful but then they're so wide
that they're very rarely actionable or
you get these very good predictors but
then we cannot estimate nice calibrated
and certainly the estimates from them so
it's it's that's a big challenge Parker
because in some sense the data doesn't
come until people see the usefulness
clinicians in particular and it was when
I was in the UK I was sitting on this in
this meeting where there was the
healthcare regulatory agency and they
were thinking of using machinery that
was in 2013 2012 and they were thinking
of using machine learning but I couldn't
they were like okay so we know we can
use machine learning but how do we know
it's useful and you could say oh we you
can develop personalized interventions
and what I but I said nobody's our new
met like this these are informed by data
and this
well we are informated where we have
case studies and so so it was it was a
hard sell and until we showed that these
predictors give you nice predictions
that that you can throw error bars
around it's good to be hard yeah I agree
with that completely I think we have a
big evaluation problem machine learning
this is something that people think
about statistics all the time and I
don't affect all the time much less than
machine learning and it's an even bigger
problem like I'm just small data we
spend a lot of time thinking about big
data that has lots of challenges but you
know small data has some very different
sorts of challenges and one of them is
just wrapped up in evaluation for
instance if I can't even withhold data
to tell how well my method is doing how
do I know this is working and how can I
prove to someone that this is going to
be useful for their field you know we
often rely on things like
cross-validation but how good is
cross-validation this is something this
is I think a surprising thing people
been using cross watching forever
decades before I got the grad school
people using cross-validation we still
don't know how it works we don't know
it's providing a good estimate if the
thing it's estimating it's only under
these very extreme circumstances that we
know that basically we know it's good if
training error is a good estimate of
your error and that's a huge open
question that you know it's those benign
answer
it's still an answer but we still use it
left and right and cheaper so what now
would add to that like saying I know
what I'm surprised as we as a research
community how little we've been able to
enforce reproducibility and really
asking if these progress like the
claimed progress in the papers is real
right especially in reinforcement
learning I mean show up in our hands I
mean I mean in a job you know has like a
long list of like papers which will not
reproducible
when I said in first man learning I mean
the more recent deep deep reinforcement
papers to clarify because they're run at
scale I mean there are run with just so
few initializations there is you know
the code is sometimes not even released
the hyper parameters are not released so
I'm just surprised at how we as a
community kind of are not able to you
know put this down into our conferences
and say you know you know if you're
claiming the result you really have to
back it up
just one point towards that it sometimes
it's just in so let's say that people
release I prefer hunters code and
architecture or whatever they're doing
which is the case for instance for
something we're working on which is
newer architecture search how do you
find the architectures of linear
networks so some of the comparisons that
we need to perform take three thousand
one hundred and sixty days GPU they
stupid so okay so Microsoft maybe we can
take offline mind GPU and just for three
hundred four three thousand days and
just crunch on it but but broad
reproducibility I think it's limited now
by computation so maybe Nvidia should
any last words Victor before we move on
Thanks okay so now I'd like to ask all
of you to think into sort of the
arbitrary future what do you think the
most surprising things that machine
learning will ultimately be able to do
that that right now
machine learning isn't making much
headway with what do you think kind of
are the limits of progress and machine
learning is sort of most that the
biggest machine learning dreams that we
should have I would say neural
programming like ultimately when and
even neural research like we you know
ultimately the machines would be able to
program themselves based on what
themselves you know there may be some
axioms there given and some you know
initial training but then after that
they can interact and they can really
you know come up with loss and
differences and make new hypotheses go
back do further experiments and to do
that in all different fields right like
how we you know think about the universe
how we think about the loss of physics
how we discover new materials I mean
there's still a distant future but that
would be an exciting future
I think I'm neural boybands will
probably be
enroll boy bands you know I think a lot
of our music will be generated by
machine learning and will actually like
to listen to it I think that that's
coming already publicly disclosed it
[Laughter]
I think machine learning on memory and
CPU constrained devices is completely
under exploited right now so an intern
this summer she was really a current
king she was really into drones and she
gave me like you know one of those
drones off the internet I don't want to
refer the cost with a twenty dollar
drone or whatever that drone does very
simple things basically as there's no
real CPU that you can think of but
imagine deploying a super simple deep
reinforcement learning model on on on
that drone you could do very interesting
things you can if you can deploy
machinery models in tiny devices you can
now the kind of the spectrum of
applications expands incredibly people
are thinking of putting mini devices in
your toilet to measure your microbiome
maybe not connected to Wi-Fi just keep
them offline but but but you could in
turn there are so many interesting
applications and that right now we're
doing huge scale machine learning on on
you know with teraflops of power but you
can imagine smaller micro blobs all
right Victor we've got boy bands and
smart toilets what else all right
so anyone else want to jump in on that
you're allowed to say more than one
thing but if not all I'll move on you've
been a really a bundle of contradictions
about deep reinforcement learning ready
I want to balance the should provide a
balanced but you know where think we are
thinking 2050 2060 so it will work hope
springs eternal okay exactly I mean you
guys aren't dreaming big enough oh I
forgot about that
[Laughter]
okay so let's not steal from the next
session we're being warned so having
talked about the you know the amazing
things that we might someday be able to
do you know machines that can program
themselves boy bands that can program
themselves whatever things toilets I
wasn't gonna go there again we all
remember that what do you think of the
things that the fundamental limits of
machine learning are what are the things
that machine learning really is never
going to be able to do but you know
really it'll it'll stop being machine
learning once when once you know certain
kinds of problems that are still kind of
within scope for computer science really
will never be part of them out I mean I
don't think there is a limit if we think
of I mean between machine learning and
artificial intelligence you know between
the terminology stuff people have that
differentiation right but if you don't
if you just talk about if we can you
know say have an adaptive system that
can really understand the environment
around it and keep learning and keep
adapting I don't see any limits
well I guess I want to encourage you to
think about machine learning kind of
narrowly rather than sort of anything
that might be called artificial
intelligence because I think that makes
it too easy so I really want to think
about you know learning from data maybe
as distinct from reasoning I think there
I mean the real limits are precisely the
data itself right like it's garbage in
garbage out so it's really then up to
the researchers and the engineers to ask
and you know the experts in that domain
to ask what is the data that's relevant
to this task how do i specify the task
what is the objective function how do I
evaluate it and that's inherently the
limitations to because those could keep
changing and it gets harder and harder
to seamlessly adapt to different ones
and there may be conflicting objectives
right how do we reconcile all that
thoughts from the rest of you you don't
have to keep going in the same order but
you can if you want I agree with that
completely
um I think the biggest limit is just
going to be the data that we've
collected that would present to our
algorithms I'm imagining this will come
up again in a future panel but we see
that you know if you're dealing with the
biased data set you're only gonna be
learning about those same biases you're
incorporating those biases into your
learned models and I think this isn't
become more and more important as we
think about interpretability because
that in essence is a human concept when
we say interpretability we mean that you
some person is able to interpret this
how do we know what that means to that
person we have to query that person we
have to query that field often and
unless be incorporating that into our
algorithms as well we can't really solve
interpretability problem and and in all
the cases where I've had to deal with
training machine learning models and
then handing them off to someone in a
field it's supposed to be benefiting
from this I'm asked you know what does
this mean why are these predictions
being made and inevitably I have to work
with that person to understand look at
my old doing I think we can push a
little bit further in producing miles
that tend to be easier to interpret but
I think without that extra human element
it's also the data produced by those
people it allows us to cause yeah
something something that they might said
in addition to the data was deciding the
objective function and and that's from
my own working computational biology
that turned out to be where I spent most
of my time right yes the data was one
maybe thirty percent of the time and
that 70 percent was what are we trying
to optimize for because we have great
function approximate errs right machine
learning we want to learn a function if
you have right data you will learn that
function the price that how do you
define what you want to learn and and it
was I was on Twitter last night and
somebody as you do and and and there was
somebody was training an agent to walk
and and basically the system could
design the length of the legs and the
articulations and the speed which works
and basically the objective was to reach
kind of like a goal line after
many obstacles and basically the system
without constraints just designed super
long legs that basically made the entire
agent collapse yeah Jackie machine like
reward 100 so so then they start
constraining length of the legs and now
it does keeping but but this is the
problem right if you just let it go on
an objective function without thinking
it will just find shortcuts there was a
thing like where there was a rocket
another another one of those toy
problems was designing a rocket that
goes up and then lands in another
location so what the what the system
found without constraints from physics
was if you go underground it's actually
consumes less energy so it's actually
designed the rocket to just point down
and just so what should we take from
this the human so as much as a so a lot
of my work now is about automating you
know to make the machine learning the
human still as much as I want that to be
that kind of result to be achieved I
think the human will still need to be
the entity that decides what you're
learning like directing the learning
towards something and so that I think
something that will never probably
automate or solve completely because the
you know if you specially you specify an
objective the system will go you know it
will do anything to achieve it and now
you start specifying too many
constraints and then you have other
problems so that's a big problem that I
may be due to lack of imagination cannot
see solve and to add to that right I
think even some of the critical failures
that will come about and that have come
about will be more human failures than
the machine learning or AI like in the
media it will be easy to say oh lo que I
failed I mean the famous one is the uber
accident of you know where the
pedestrian was actually detected by the
sensor so it was not a technological
failure but it was a failure in terms of
like you know how the processing did
not reach like the end decision right
and and so if the system was extensively
tested it would have been definitely
caught because you know there is we all
know about false alarm and detection
curves so we can like ask where are we
in that operating wave what is the
operating point in that curve and so it
was and then make a decision based on
that and so in this case you know like
either it slipped through or that was it
was decided that we would just like you
know have this human driver who would
just kind of take care of any failure of
machine learning but that's again not
taking into account the human attention
span sigh you know like kind of they're
continuously driving forever and the
chances of failure are are tiny but when
they happen that catastrophic right so I
think we'll still face a lot of
challenges in many such domains where AI
system will be in the loop with the
critical decision-making and even having
human or many humans who may not be the
solution well so niccolò and anima both
in your last responses kind of raised
this idea of how people are going to be
reacting kind of in real-time to
deployed ml systems and I think this
really touches on this question of the
limits of ml it seems like right now you
know we haven't gotten very good sort of
socially at understanding these limits
and understanding the boundaries of
where these systems break down how we
ought to interact with them do you guys
think this is something that we're gonna
get better at do you think the systems
are gonna have to adapt in a way to make
it easier for us to do this and you know
if so do you have any thoughts on you
know what that might look like I think
it's gonna get worse as these systems
get more widely deployed possibly yeah
so I think there is so now there is and
there are people working on it but there
is still compared to the size of the
problem and the size of the machine
learning field there is a very narrow
contact surface in between which is HCI
work human-computer interaction so
things such as understanding and
visualizing uncertainty providing it to
the
as a feedback to the to the human
operator or the human making decision is
still something that is poorly
understood and and to be developed there
is some there is some work but it's very
specific right last night at dinner was
talking about there is an app called
dark sky that it does now casting of the
weather which is very useful in Boston
because you don't want to get soaked and
and it predicts basically a time series
of rain intensity and uncertainty
estimate is super important because
people then there is a whole book about
it which actually our social media
collective right which was about
following the National Weather Service
and kind of studying how they think
about and certainly in predictions it's
called masters of uncertainty and
software for weather prediction
uncertainty conveying uncertainty about
your your prediction is super important
and this time series the way the app
does it it shows basically a smooth kind
of like Gaussian process looking line
that shows the boundaries of the
uncertainty and stuff like that is
absolutely brilliant because it tells it
allows you to understand what's going on
but it's very narrowly focused on some
domains right now and we need more
contact service but it seems like it
allows you to know what's going on if
you're already very good at thinking
about uncertainty it seems like a broad
population it has a lot of trouble
thinking about you know probabilistic
statements or are we gonna get better as
a society because we're gonna be so
surrounded by these things or the system
is gonna have to adapt I think we will
need to get more educated so first for
the elections right the New York Times
is another version of these uncertainty
estimates things where you have a dial
that goes Republican or Democrat and
they added like a jitter to show the
uncertainty around and the beginning was
terrifying and then and it was going
from side to side showing broad and
certainty estimates and so people
actually turn it off and in the most
recent I think it was the midterms the
naughty meters but the you know feeling
the vacancies they New York Times didn't
have it anymore I think so people just
ask to be I mean we should discuss
politics or
Carroll but see there we go but I'm
reminded of the the last presidential
election where you know at the last
minute
Clinton was forecast to win by something
like 70/30 and then you know when when
the unexpected thing happened everyone
said how were the polls so wrong it's
like well sometimes 30 percent
probability things happen maybe if you
have a well calibrated model this should
be happening 30 percent and somehow
people don't don't even seem to think
that way even about binary choices so
what hope do we have about you know
richer model spaces I think this is
further I think you know it's gonna be
harder if you you know assign like a
human-like nature to the system sort
especially robots or you know things
that looked like a humanoid outer car
that you think is being driven by a
human but it's not so you tend to assign
the same kind of qualities and the same
kind of behavioral response from a human
and so there I think a lot of maybe even
if we give uncertainty estimates you
kind of ignore all that and you just go
back to you know how you would expect a
human to react and I think that's even
more dangerous well I guess this this
comes back to your notion before if
objective functions and also what the
victor brought up before about kind of
causal reasoning about really being able
to you know ascribe some kind of causal
motivation it seems to me that this is
another place where machine learning has
been very fruitful but also where
there's sort of an inherent tension
about reasoning from data because you
want to understand something
counterfactual you don't necessarily
want to understand only what the data
has to tell you is there an inherent
limit there yeah yeah so it's it's
actually interesting how how different
fields think about the same questions in
a very different way so I spend like two
days in chipping in with Burnham Shoko
and so his lab is is devoting all of its
attention out to causal questions of
causal inference
and and then they they want to automate
the causal discoveries but it seems like
it's really hard to do so without
contextual knowledge without experts
being brought in and so on just like
really simplistic approach is saying
let's assume that we have a dog or
something like this like a diagram
without cycles and then let's just
discover it often goes wrong like it
will go wrong and supply-demand systems
right because it's not really a dag and
so on and without knowing the context I
think it would could could go terribly
wrong said I don't know how to automate
this and so on and people mentioned here
quantification of uncertainty here I
don't think we all agree on what what
the uncertainty means like I mean I
would be surprised again like if
somebody has a good quantification
uncertainty for given your own nets like
if they if you have a prediction for
based on them I would be interested in
in saying a confidence interval at the
classical one the frequent just one just
and and but but and it's even for
prediction the counter for a
counterfactual prediction is much much
harder because we have to create and buy
signals about the treatment effects or
causal effects and and the constructions
or constructions of such an buy signal
is often relies on experiments
experiments I'm not available for the
most interesting questions research
questions that we have like yeah the
experience can be used to measure
short-run effects that give you an idea
about the the the true causes but we're
so far away from from from learning
long-run effects and from automating the
learning
okay all right this is the first thing
that spurred our audience to activate
and I think going back to your question
about you know how will we adapt through
this basically new world I think I think
we have to but when I say we I really
mean the younger generations aware so
little faith in the new world we're old
but I think there is hope for education
I think a lot of universities are
already starting to integrate you know
statistical education into like the
standard curriculum for all students
I've seen data science 101 courses
popping up at places like Stanford and
Berkeley I think we need to go farther
back than that because now we already
have I mean these systems are being
deployed we already have machine many
systems that are just you know helping
to decide who's gonna get it released on
bail I mean that's affecting your life
your life and what's going to happen you
know well you end up in jail or released
with your family and that's gonna happen
more and more so it means the new
generations will have to be educated on
these things that so I think it is
difficult to take someone like me and to
be retrained into thinking about
uncertainty but I think if we start
early
we can so we shouldn't even have faith
in former stats professors from Stanford
even though there's no hope for the rest
of us point estimates catch them early
that should be the public health so
should calculus and high schools be
replaced by statistics Monte augmented
[Laughter]
stochastic calculus okay so we've talked
a bunch about the the limits of ml you
know both you know how ml is gonna grow
and also you know what what maybe
ultimately it's going to constrain it if
we imagine that you know all of our
machine learning dreams are realized
machine learning takes its you know
appropriate place at the center of
computer science ruling the world what
other areas of computer science and and
maybe of the sciences more generally are
going to increase in importance because
of their kind of inherent
complementarity to
to the place the machine learning will
ultimately reach and I think this is
particularly important given that MSR
New England is such an interdisciplinary
place so we're here really to celebrate
MSR New England and I think you know in
the kind of interdisciplinary lab of the
future you know if you're gonna be
centered on ML now who else do you need
to make sure you have around I mean so I
you know what Celtic as well like you
know it's a very interdisciplinary place
right and we recently launched AI for
science with the goal of really having
AI it make an impact in all areas of
Sciences and so to me like yes you know
there should be a central overarching
machine learning affecting all the
fields but ultimately it's also has to
bring in all the domain experts you know
so transfer some of the machine learning
knowledge to them and for them to also
further develop machine learning right
so it's not gonna be like a few of
machine learning researchers just
solving all the world's problems you
know I think that would be also to our
again two things that a few of us could
do that but instead it would really be
machine learning itself getting
democratized spreading its wings and the
basic you know grounding is present for
all sciences in fact all kind of all the
areas of Education including the arts
right and then you know it's up to every
researcher and every field to say what
is I know how is this gonna be relevant
to me and how can I further develop what
are the domain constraints I have you
know is that small data regime is that
the large data is the interactive
learning is it you know mostly kind of
online learning so all these like a word
aspect is really relevant to my field
and how do I value it right so we have
to really broaden machine learning
rather than centralize it when I was
graduate student at Berkeley I was part
of this interdisciplinary the
interdisciplinary lab which was called
the rat labs it was essentially machine
it was a systems plus machine learning
lab but the goal was the goal the
machine learning piece was to develop
machine learning that be useful for
systems by the end of my time at grad
school had been replaced by a new lab
called the amp lab and again was the
systems of machine learning lab but then
it was about building systems that would
support machine learn
and I think that's been a crucial part
to you know scaling up machine learning
dealing with all the big data problems
that we have making use of parallel
processing dealing with cloud computing
so systems in particular I think is one
really good having there a number of
answers but that's one particular area
that we need yeah I think that would
have been one of my answers to the the
first question about what's been
surprising in the last ten years is the
extent to which breakthroughs in ml have
been systems breakthroughs rather than
then theory breakthroughs I should say
GP well it probably it's easy to see
because it's such a the strength of the
New England lab but the combination of
quantitatively minded people and
qualitatively minded people is is a
powerful one so having humanists around
and engaging with them is is a crazy
powerful combination and because
sometimes machinery it's easy to get
tangled up in just I can answer this so
why not do it and and sometimes it's
useful to direct your attention to what
should you really answer not just
because you can't but because you should
and those usually that they are they're
questions that are more profound and and
it's useful to have people will kind of
bathe the you in in in those eight years
- comment - along that line right so you
know these days I give talks to broad
audiences and also around the world you
know like really reach out to you know
people with maybe not having the math
background and so so many of them worry
like how do I participate in this
machine learning revolution how do I you
know I want to learn but where do I
start
and and so that's been another great
thing there are efforts like fast or AI
and other community efforts that are
really making it easy for people to not
only deploy machine learning but to
write simple code to have very
accessible examples and I think it's so
crucial that we make the education about
machine learning and in through a
corollary even math right like much more
kind of accessible
two broad population with maybe who may
be thinking in different ways and that's
the only way we're gonna make progress
by moving humanity in creating better
machine learning and designing better
even you know forms of machine learning
and I think online education is
important like I could say I've
benefited a lot from undo eggs course
and deep learning I just love the
programming and so on learned a lot very
easy to like for a busy person it's
really nice to second I think we it's
the community is really important I
really enjoyed my time at MSR like you
have great community like really open
open-minded people coming from different
fields and working together discussing
and breaking language barriers and so on
that that was fantastic
in some ways what we have now at the
Center for statistics and data science
is very similar in nature you have
different people coming from different
different departments working in stats
and machine learning
probably defined we created educational
programs like minor in stats double the
ph.d program in in in accent statistics
a mathematics and statistics economics
and statistics and so on we I think we
have the best well we have the best
seminar I believe like it's called
stochastic and statistics seminar it's
like the the the really love the seminar
lots of people come in it's really
really nice
presentations with theorems and proven
so we yeah we started this undergraduate
on the graduate program which is a be a
Bachelor of Science in computer science
economics and data science so that's I
think that's a
big changer game-changer for us at least
so to connect something that came up in
a lot of your different answers I
particularly like what Niccolo said
about you humanists being being useful
to this broader enterprise of machine
and you may be connecting to what lester
was saying about the new generation but
imagine that you're you know an aspiring
academic in some area that you you're
never gonna be a machine learning
researcher but but you believe that
machine learning is gonna be you know a
really important part of the future you
know maybe you're you're a social
scientist maybe you're you're a theorist
maybe you're a you know scientist and
some other discipline what do you need
to do differently compared to maybe the
the generation of academics before you
in your own discipline to be better
positioned to be working it was part of
this machine learning enterprise to be
working alongside and all people already
first is the data right so I would say
you know what you know can you have an
acai are you able to kind of put
together the data that's there in the
field maybe it's in disparate forms and
you know maybe there's even missing ones
but at the very least can you try to
bring that all together and ask you know
by combining the datasets and I even
collecting new data can I really no
answer questions I couldn't before
and I'm working with machine learning
scientists I think it has to be a close
collaboration because that's the only
way like kind of you know both the sides
can learn from each other so those are
the two things I would say yeah I agree
with that
and I think the only thing would add was
probably try to get a job from Jennifer
[Laughter]
working together on problems you know
that you you you have a scientist that
has a domain knowledge and has a problem
he or she should be able to approach and
talk a machine-learning scientist to
help solve the problem there should be
common educational base to be able to
speak to get on the same page quickly I
mean I guess I want to open that box a
little bit though I don't just want to
talk about the value of talking together
or the value of having a job from
Jennifer I want the recipe for having a
drug from Jennifer what what is the
skill set that people are going to need
what are they going to have to actually
you know develop as you know a toolkit
to be able to to engage in those
collaborations usefully so you know what
Caltech we have now a new data science
major and minor that's you know across
campus anybody can take right so the the
minor especially so I think augmenting
like the core area or the core major
with a minor in data science would be a
great start because you have the
fundamentals and if you're out of school
to you know do the online courses to you
know I tell a lot of you know candidates
so that I get who want to get into
machine learning I point them to the
resources these Jupiter notebooks are
great they have explanations but they
also have working code to really
hands-on try it on different data sets
you know explore the failure modes right
I think that's what really distinguishes
somebody with a surface knowledge of
machine learning and somebody who's
deeper is okay why are things failing
how do i D bug how do I resolve that and
to participate in online forums I mean
there's just so much activity happening
online and even in meetups and workshops
so there's a lot of community driven
efforts and I think being part of it
would be a great start yeah let me give
you an example from that that I've seen
with my own eyes
so during my my PhD I was in a Institute
for translational science so I was we
were a machine learning group embedded
with biologists and these biologists
received training some of them 10 years
ago 12 years ago at the time and you
know they went through stats and math
courses and computer science basic
computer science courses but for a lot
of them it was not a core
core coursework so they did it was just
pass or fail yeah you pass that's good
job so then they realize and then do
there was this machine learning group
and we our goal was to kind of work an
intersection of fields and they would
come with their microarray data and time
it was microarrays and they would say
okay I will need to under understand
differential expression between brain
tissue to test the disease and brain
tissue that doesn't have the disease and
we would you know being machine learning
people we pop something calculate the
p-value but then they realize that the
turnaround time was long that we maybe
didn't super look at calibration
p-values that sometimes when you fit
things
comparisons you should control we were
controlling better ways so the under so
okay so these people are busy they're
doing their you know
machinery papers why don't we pick it up
ourselves and so they started getting
their own training stats and we rapidly
found that once they got is training in
stats that would be super competitive
what we could come up with
look it basically get 95% of the way
there but because that the training then
they could communicate more effectively
with us what what they would their
wishes were from the system and so we at
that point there was this feedback loop
where we could understand better what
they were looking for they when there's
better what our models were doing and so
they learn more machine learning we
learn more biology and and that was like
a virtual cycle yeah I'm a bit surprised
that so far the answer is you guys are
giving or about how people in other
disciplines should sort of learn some
machine learning themselves to sort of
don't stop your stats but but should you
know kind of learn the toolkit that I
know people have to sort of meet in the
middle I'm wearing sort of an economics
hat I'm particularly excited by the idea
of complements you know what are you
know entirely different things where
people might lean in an opposite
direction to really develop a skill set
that ml people don't have but that's
going to be really relevant and in a
world with a lot of ml people human
interaction I mean you know so I think
that I mean to be more serious it'll be
a really important in the future right
so it's not just a mathematical
ability but to communicate to different
areas to you know empathize with the
difficulties the different sections of
population have or or different fields
are facing so how we can you know learn
from others to you know help us all
better problems because if you define
the set of all possible other fields and
then you say what's the compliment well
sorry I feel like machine learning is
large like a field of immigrants I mean
being a pretty young field a lot of
these people came in from from other
aspects of other disciplines computer
science from mathematics from physics
quite often and so they're all I don't
see I guess I disagree with a thrust of
the question and that I do think the
best thing for them is to go and learn
machine learning to and then augment
their their own skill set with that I
don't know yeah but that's how what I
approach it well if I can't get you to
disagree with each other at least I can
get you to disagree with me so we're
just in the last seconds left and let me
just invite you each to give some
closing thoughts if you have any sort of
how do we get there from here what what
are the things we should all be focusing
on as a group to do you realize the
vision that we spent the last night
we're talking about I mean for me it
would be bridging theory and practice
right to ask you know like what are the
current blind spots in practice can we
design better algorithms and also you
know really explore the failure modes of
those algorithms and keep iterating so
it's never kind of gonna be you know
it's always kind of you know gone but to
make it much more of a process that's
easy to do and to focus more on data yes
for me the most important things are
just breaking gaps between theory and
practice
there's just a gigantic gap out there
and the second is breaking communication
barriers like there's a lot of data
science activities we need to go we need
to understand each other better yeah I'd
love to see a broader dissemination of
problems I think research teams a bit of
be a bit myopic we come up with a
problem we try to solve ourselves we
can't solve that we shelf it gel bed and
and the problem dies or maybe as we
discovered you know I'm a decade later
quite often but we might know what the
right problems are but not the right
solutions I think we're at a time with
in the current and our current
environment it's very easy to reach out
to the the broad community we already
start to see this with machine learning
competitions for instance where you know
someone knows there's a particular
problem that needs to be solved they're
willing to like you know put out lots of
money so somebody else can solve it and
you end up finding solutions from places
where you wouldn't normally look often
from different disciplines and I think
that's probably the way forward forget
to making the base contributions to
humanity
broadly my main point is we should be
worrying more about good scholarship in
machine learning so there is this great
paper that is on the archive which is
troubling trends in machine learning
scholarship we are not always doing a
great job disentangling for instance the
sources of an empirical gain in
performance and we should be thinking
more about that so people should read
that paper and think about it it's a
very interesting concept great and let's
let's thank all of our panelists
[Applause]